well mayor john lee says north las vegas
is an extraordinary city that was his
theme during
the 25th annual virtual state of the
city address the mayor claims the city
has been a model for the response to the
pandemic for spending federal funds
effectively to help the local economy
lee said before the pandemic the
residential market was matching demands
of the southwest valley another economic
milestone
is the southern nevada water water
authority's decision to develop 18 miles
of new water line
and 40 miles of sewage infrastructure
2021 is going to be a great year we have
great expectations for the city of north
las vegas
because of what we've already put in
place
no doubt there will be challenges but we
are moving forward
the city also has three new industrial
parks planned along the pipeline route
that will translate into more jobs
city leaders also highlighted their
launch of the southern nevada urban
micro academy as well as the renovated
fire station to operate as the harbor
which serves families in need